Ja, ich schaue.
Yaldis ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz erstätig.
Ich würde gerne das Aufnahmegeschichte mit Ihnen führen.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen, soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen?
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Nein.
Schlecht reden. Hören Sie mich.
Ja, ich höre äh...
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Daniela Müller.
Daniela Müller.
Bei Müller und Daniela beide ist es Double L.
Daniela nur mit einem L?
Einem L.
Müller mit zwei.
Zwei. Okay.
Frau Müller, wie alt bin ich Sie?
Ich bin 21 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
10. März 2004.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,60 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell, wissen Sie?
55 kg.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Frau Müller?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit zwei Tagen eine heisere Stimme.
Ganz starke Halsschmerzen.
Und ich habe hier auf der rechten Seite eine große Schwellung.
Ich kann kaum schlucken, das tut weh.
So, ich rede wieder normal, damit man mich versteht.
Okay.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Frau Müller, Sie haben Sie leiden an unter zwei Tagen
eine heiser Stimme und Halsschmerzen und rechten Seite eine große Schwellung.
Ja.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Immer schlimmer geworden. Okay, verstehe ich.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Ihre Schmerzen,
wie Ihre Schmerzen, beschreiben Sie Ihre Schmerzen,
druckende, tieende oder so?
Also, ich kann seit gestern Abend kaum schlucken.
Meine eigene Spucke muss ich rausspucken.
Es ist einfach ein sehr starker Schmerz.
Manchmal ist es stechend, aber es strahlt halt aus.
Es strahlt in den Kopf.
Ja, aber mehr hier im Halsbereich.
Mehr als bereit, aber strahlt im Kopf.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Strehend, druckend oder nur stehend?
Kann ich Sie einfach schmerzen? Kann ich schlecht beschreiben?
Okay.
Sie stehen Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10.
Also, seit gestern 8 oder noch?
Sie haben Schluckprobleme, sehr starker Schluckprobleme.
Ja, ich kann kaum, wenn ich Wasser trinke, ich kann das kaum runterschlucken.
Haben Sie noch etwas bemerkt, zum Beispiel Fibar oder Schuttelfrost?
Ja, ja, seit gestern habe ich auch Fibar.
Und heute Morgen musste ich auch zittern und frieren.
Also sehr unangenehm.
Ja, ich verstehe, das ist sehr, sehr unangenehme.
Wie können Ihnen helfen?
Haben Sie zu Hause Ihre Körpertemperatur gemessen?
Nein, aber ich fühle mich sehr warm an und wenn ich mich so antrachte,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich glühle.
Ja, verstehe.
Nehmen Sie eine Medikamente?
Haben Sie ein Medikament gegen diese Beschwerde eingenommen?
Ich habe versucht Paracetamol zu schlucken,
aber seit heute Morgen kann ich kaum schlucken.
Gestern habe ich noch schlucken können.
Heute klappt es nicht mehr.
Haben Sie noch etwas Schwellen bemerkt,
im Ihre Akserhöre oder andere Körpertemperatur?
Nein, das ist nur hier.
Nur rechtzeitig.
Ja.
Entschuldige.
Haben Sie im Spiegel Ihre Mandel gesehen,
vergrößert oder?
Ich kann meinen Mund kaum öffnen.
Es tut sehr stark weh.
Da müssen Sie bitte reinschauen,
als ich meinen Mund nicht mehr aufbekomme.
Ja, das ist nicht wichtig.
Wir werden untersuchen, kein Problem.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerde bemerkt?
Ja, mein Atem riecht sehr stark
und ganz schlimm.
Es kommt ein ganz schlimmer Geruch aus meinem Mund.
Ja, Mundgeruch.
Haben Sie Luft-Nord-Probleme?
Noch geht es, aber ich arbeite über die Nase.
Aber ich fühle mich sehr geschwächt, sehr krank.
Ich möchte nur noch schlafen,
aber die Schmerzen sind einfach schlimm.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechenprobleme?
Nein.
Haben Sie, wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ich habe seit zwei Tagen eigentlich kaum gegessen.
Ich fühle mich sehr müde und matt.
Ich habe keinen großen Hunger.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Ich könnte den ganzen Tag schlafen, wenn die Schmerzen nicht wären.
Ja.
Frau Müller, ich würde gerne wissen,
Ihre Krankenvorgeschichte.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Also bisher ist nichts bekannt, nein.
Gut. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente?
Nein, nur die Pille.
Leiden Sie, ist bei Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ich habe nur eine Polenallergie, aber sonst nicht.
Wie reagieren Sie?
Wie die Nase läuft, die Augen tränen, ich muss immer ständig niesen.
Aber dann nehme ich Zitrizen und das hilft mir sehr gut.
Noch andere Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, bisher nicht bekannt.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Sie rauchen?
Nein.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine rutine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Ja, ich habe uns mal probiert.
Ab und zu?
Ja, ab und zu habe ich probiert.
Ab und zu probieren Sie auch?
Nein, also nur beim Fest oder auf einer Party.
Welche, Cannabis oder?
Überwiegend Cannabis, LSD, härtere Sachen habe ich jetzt noch nicht getestet.
Ab und zu habe ich schon gesagt, ich bin ehrlich, hingegengegen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen als Verhütungsmitteile regelmäßig.
Ja.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frau Arzt regelmäßig?
Nicht regelmäßig, aber einmal im Jahr.
Gibt es auffällig?
Aufhelligkeiten? Nein.
Alles okay.
Wann ist Ihre letzte Periode?
Ich glaube, das war vor zwei Wochen.
Waren Sie im letzten sechs Monaten aus dem Land?
Im Ausland? Nein.
Entschuldige, sind Sie alle Impfungen vollständig geimpft?
Ich meine, ob ich alle Impfungen habe.
Impfungen?
Ja, ich glaube, mein Haushalt hat das immer kontrolliert.
Die müssten vollständig sein.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Ihre Eltern noch leben?
Leben, ja, ja.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, nein, ich habe, also die Eltern meinen Sie?
Ja, Eltern meinen.
Ach so, meine Mutter hat einen leicht erhöhtes Kollesterin, hat sie mir gesagt.
Und der Vater nimmt Medikamente gegen seinen hohen Blutdruck.
Haben Sie Geschwester? Nein.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Studentin, ich studiere Jura und bin im dritten Semester.
Was studieren Sie?
Jura.
Was meine Sie, Jura?
Rechts, Wissenschaften.
Sind Sie Lady?
Ja, aber ich hatte einen Partner, ich hatte einen Freund.
Keine Kinder? Nein.
Im letzten zwei, drei Tage haben Sie Bauchschmerzen bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Wasser lassen oder Stuhlgangprobleme?
Also, ob ich Wasser lassen und beim Wasser lassen, nein, habe ich nicht.
Stuhlgang ist auch in Ordnung.
Ich habe alle wichtige für mich gestellt, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerde bemerkt, in letzter Zeit?
Nein, also, wenn Sie mir sagen können, was es ist und was man machen muss.
Ja, ich denke, das ist eine Nothen, Herr Großjahrung, aber ich kann zuzeit nicht genau sagen,
wir sollen zuerst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen, nachdem können wir wieder schippeln.
Okay. Wollen Sie mal reinschauen?
Wollen Sie in meinen Hals reinschauen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also, ich bekomme meinen Mund kaum auf und alles weh.
Sie können jetzt mit dem Spatel auf die Zunge drücken.
Ja.
Und Sie sehen, was sehen Sie?
Eine rechte Tonne Sille, also Mandel, stark geschwollen, gerötet und eine ganz weisen, oberflächlichen Abdeckung oder Belag.
Und es riecht extrem.
Ja, verstehe.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Haben Sie laufende oder verstopfte Nase?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Und höchsten?
Wenig, aber halt schon mehr.
Okay.
Ich werde, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Partner oder andere gibt es?
Also, meine Partner, nein, ich bin der einzige.
Okay.
Ramila, haben Sie in nächster Zeit Ab-Auto zugenommen?
Nein, nein, ich bin mir nichts aufgefunden. Mein Gewicht ist gleich.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder Epistaxen, Nase und Blutung?
Nase und Blutung habe ich jetzt nicht, aber Kopfschmerzen, ja.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Autodeugen in nächster Zeit merkwisch veränderungen werden?
Nein, nein, ich bin mir nichts aufgefallen. Nein.
Haben Sie auch Auswurf dabei?
Also, ich habe manchmal Hofstin, aber es kommt einfach so ein weiser Zehrschleim.
Könnt ihr erst jetzt die Sprache anfangen, oder?
Ja.
Okay, bitte schön.
Okay.
Ich möchte eine neue Patientin vorstellen, darf ich?
Aber natürlich, Herr Kollege, bitte schön.
Frau Daniela Müller ist ein 21-jähriger Patientin, zeitlich örtlich und persönlich orientiert in normalgewichtigem Ernährungszustand und beschwerde Bedingte durch reduziertem Algermainzustand.
Die Patientin stellte sich auf unsere Station mit seit zwei Tagen bestehenden, probedienten, Heiserkeit und Servikalgie mit Ausstrahlung im Kopf oder im Kopf vor.
Nach Aussage der Patientin hat sie rechtzeitig Servikaladenopathie, Servikal-Schwellung bemerkt.
Sie leidet auch unter dysphagie, der starke dysphagie.
Die Intensität der Schmerzen wurde mit acht Pfonsien auf nummerisches Skala angegeben.
Sie klagte über Plexi und Schutelfrost, aber sie haben nicht zu Hause gemessen.
Sie berichtet, dass sie Fatiguë und Astheny zu leiden.
Sie berichtet, dass sie Fatiguë und Astheny zu leiden haben.
Die Frage auf Nausea, Vomitus und Gewichtverlust wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf oben genannte Symptome und beschwerde bedingte Inapetanz und Insomnia unauffällig.
Wie sieht der Hals aus?
Sie meint, es ist ein eintriger Belag auf der rechten Tonzehne.
Die Patientin klagte über schlechte Mundgeruch.
Die Frage auf Polenenergie und Rhinokonjunktivitis zu reagieren.
Sie berichtet, dass sie nicht auf der Leitung sind.
Sie trinken regelmäßig kein Alkohol. Sie probieren ab und zu Drogen Cannabis oder LCT nur am Feier oder Party.
Imfungstatus sei vollständig.
Anfamilien Anamnese ergab eine arterielle Hypertonie bei dem Vater, die Mutter der Patientin leidet an Hypercholestronomie.
Sie ist Studentin von Jure. Sie lebt und hat keine Kinder.
Sie lebt mit einem Partnerin oder Partner?
Sie lebt mit einem Partnerin oder Partnerin oder Partnerin.
Sie lebt mit einem Partnerin oder Partnerin.
Sie lebt mit Antibiotische Therapie.
Sie lebt mit einem Antibiotikum. Sie lebt mit einem Antibiotikum.
Haben die Kollegen noch andere Vorschläge?
Diese Patientin ist Ihre Patient, oder?
Ja, kam gestern zu mir.
Haben Sie Wertsdiagnose gestartet?
Ich habe sie zum Halsnasen Ohrenarzt geschickt.
Ich habe sie im Mund gewohnt, dass ich befürchtet habe, dass man die Tonsille spalten muss, also operieren muss.
Ich habe dann gedacht, dass man einfach als entscheidet, ob man nur eine Antibiose gibt oder ob man vielleicht operieren muss.
Ich habe leider noch kein Ergebnis. Ich weiß nicht, was man mit ihr gemacht hat.
Als Haushalts-Präsident kann man das machen.
Ich glaube, es ist bestimmt ein Auslöser dafür.
Es hat plötzlich angefangen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Laborentesuchen?
Nein, ich habe nichts gemacht. Ich habe sie direkt zum Halsnasen Ohrenarzt als Akkurtpatientin geschickt.
Bezugsweise ins Krankenhaus.
Deswegen müssen wir am Anfang nicht Antibiotik.
Das ist nicht falsch. Aber wenn es ein MBV wäre, dann ist eine Amoxicillin richtig oder falsch?
Amoxicillin ist falsch.
Ja, eine Ohrarzt, Ärztin. Frau Ärztin, eine Ohr, bitte.
Amoxicillin kann Hautausschlag auslösen bei infektiöser Maneuropieklose.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Deswegen muss man schon genau wissen, ist das MBV oder ist es Eidrige-Tonsilitis?
Bei MBV gibt man kein Penicillin.
Das kann auch in der Prüfung kommen. Muss man aufpassen.
Ja, habe ich einen Kollegen noch in der Frage.
Vielleicht sollte man auch hier wie Mobus Chronus Colitis, zwischen einer MBV Infektion und einer Eidrigen-Tonsilitis ganz gut kennen.
Therapie, Diagnostik, die Unterschiede.
Ich denke, das ist eine schöne Prüfungsfrage.
Ja, ich denke.
Ich habe eine Minute.
Ich möchte wissen, wie wir das unterscheiden.
Mit Abstrich oder mit Blutweite?
Ihr seid die Ärzte, wir haben davorhin eine Halsnase-Oren-Ärzte gehabt.
Es gibt noch eine Schnelltest.
Ich bin nicht ein Hausarzt, aber wir machen eine bei den Schnelltest.
Ja, ich glaube, für die Streptokoppen gibt es auch einen Schnelltest.
Ja, es gibt noch.
Mit Schnelltest kann man mit Kids arbeiten.
Man kann Blut abnehmen und gut nachweisen, ob es EBV ist oder nicht.
Welcher Wert ist bei einer akuten EBV Infektion hoch?
EBV IgM.
IgM, ja.
Antebner.
Akutphase, Protein.
Das ist dann hoch.
So kann man den Unterschied feststellen.
Was haben EBV Infektionen meistens noch Begleitreaktionen?
Außer Halsschmerzen?
Spleinomekali.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich habe gefragt, Bauchschmerzen oder insbesondere linksseitige.
Sie haben gefragt und die Patientin sagt, nein.
Aber wir reden jetzt über die Symptome und die Beschwerden bei ihr Befraudes.
Ist EBV verursacht nur eine seitliche Entschwörung?
Meistens doppelseitig.
Doppelseitig, ja.
Sie haben großflächige, beidseitige Weise Abladungen.
Ja, ich weiß.
Das sind die Unterschiede zwischen EBV und Streptokorben.
Bakterienentschwörung.
Was sind Sie für ein Facharzt, Herr Kollege?
Anesthesi.
Ich habe vergessen, alle Aufnahmen und Untersuchungen.
Ja, das ist unser.
Sie geben einfach Gas in den Mund und fertig.
Ja.
Sehr gut. Vielen Dank.
Ist sehr gut, Herr Doktor.
Aber Sie müssen aufpassen, wenn Sie schnell reden, dann machen Sie sehr schnell grammatikalische Fehler.
Ja, ja.
Verwechseln Sie oder die Artikel, eigentlich wissen Sie das, eigentlich können Sie das.
Sie sind ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Und da kommt die Frage sehr schnell.
Da ist der Satzbau manchmal.
Aber ich finde das nicht schlimm, aber ich weiß nicht, wie Sie,
wie die Prüfer in der Prüfung das bewerten, ob die darauf großen Wert legen oder nicht.
Vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer reden.
Langsam reden.
Ich denke, Sie können das sehr gut. Sie haben keine Eile.